Okay.
So, you can clearly see some things going on here.
First, let's talk about one of the most obvious...
...which is the hairline.
Now, even though this shade works really great...
...all over Jacqueline's face...
I mean, it's a perfect shade throughout the center of her face.
Most people, when you get up towards the hairline,...
...that skin gets a little bit darker.
So, if you bring the foundation right to the hairline...
...in the same amount of coverage,...
...what you end up with is this line of demarcation.
So, without bringing it into her hairline,...
...which is gonna get foundation all over her hair,....
...it's gonna be a big mess.
I'm gonna show you later a much easier way to fix this,...
...which is basically by allowing the foundation from around this point...
...to stop and then just softly blend into natural skin color,...
...and it'll create a much more natural look.
But that's a really obvious one and one that I see quite a lot...
...because we think, I got to put the foundation...
...all the way right up to my hairline and stop.
Now, when you look at the jawline,...
...here's another area where we get into a similar problem.
A lot of times when we're doing our makeup or looking at a mirror,...
...there's a light coming down and we see shadow here.
So, we just apply the foundation to here and we stop.
Without blending it down, you start to get this mask effect as well.
You get a slight difference in the shade...
...between here and your neck,...
...and it just tends to bring out the effect of a makeup look.